We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Go hide your tears, you lamb. Let them burlame. Everybody recognizes it when they see it.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。去把你的眼泪藏起来，小羊羔。让他们……每个人一看到它都能认出来。
Sort of has a castles with turrets look. On the left and the right hand side, there are some taller towers and then it sort of dips in the middle. It's the periodic table of elements. The bricks of the tower are the individual elements, all of the 118 elements that scientists know exist. And the way they're arranged on the table is that elements that have very similar properties and characteristics.
看起来有点像带炮塔的城堡。左边和右边有一些更高的塔楼，然后中间微微下陷。这就是元素周期表。塔上的砖块就是单个元素，也就是科学家们知道存在的全部118种元素。它们在表上的排列方式是，具有非常相似属性和特征的元素……
Similar properties like melting points and similar chemical reactions with other elements are in the same vertical column on the table. Gallon. The film I'm talking to is Sam Keene. My name is Sam Keene. The book is The Disappearing Spoon and other two tales of madness, love, and the history of the world from the periodic table of the elements.
诸如熔点相似以及与其他元素有相似化学反应的相似属性，在表中的同一垂直列中。镓。我正在对话的电影人是萨姆·基恩。我的名字是萨姆·基恩。这本书是《消失的汤匙：来自元素周期表的疯狂、热爱与世界历史的其他故事》。
The periodic table is a strange case of design duality. It's a design of both extreme success. And I think a little bit of failure. Let's do the failure first. You know, it's different than other scientific icons in that it's hard to just look at it and get information and glance from it. Even though it probably hung in front of you every day that you went to school, my guess is, very little of its information really sunk in. One of the bad designs of it, it's not something that's intuitive until you've done a lot of work, which I guess doesn't make it all that intuitive. So that's the bad part.
元素周期表是一个设计二元性的奇怪例子。它既是一个极其成功的设计，我想，也带有一点失败。我们先来看看失败的地方。你知道，它与其他科学标志不同，你很难只看一眼就能从中获取信息并一目了然。尽管它可能每天都挂在你上学时的教室前方，但我的猜测是，它真正深入你脑海的信息非常少。它糟糕的设计之一在于，在你做大量工作之前它并不那么直观，这我想也让它没那么直观了。所以这是糟糕的部分。
But the impertibility is far outweighed by its beauty, and the condition and predictive power, and here's where we should introduce the hero of the story. The hero of the story is Dmitri Mendeleyev, a Russian scientist. Mendeleyev wasn't the first to come up with a periodic system. There were five others before him, but he's still the periodic table, Mac Daddy. He came up with a design and incorporated more elements than the other scientists could, and he also knew enough to predict that there were holes on the periodic table. He left gaps.
但它的不可理解性远远被其美感、逻辑性和预测能力所掩盖，在这里我们应该介绍一下故事的主人公。故事的主人公是德米特里·门捷列夫，一位俄国科学家。门捷列夫并不是第一个提出周期系统的人。在他之前还有另外五个人，但他仍然是元素周期表的大佬。他提出了一个设计，并比其他科学家纳入了更多的元素，而且他有足够的远见预测元素周期表上存在空缺。他留下了空白。
That would be filled by later elements that people discovered. So he knew enough to be able to predict the properties of new elements based on where exactly the holes were. This was huge. That's why he gets more credit than the other five scientists do. Mendeley have loved his table, but everyone else was about to discover how awesome it was when the first gap of the table was filled in with an element newly-christened gallium. This was discovered in 1875 by a Frenchman. And gallium filled in the gap right below aluminum, and because of that.
这些空白将由人们后来发现的元素来填补。因此，他掌握了足够的知识，能够根据空白的准确位置来预测新元素的属性。这太了不起了。这就是为什么他比其他五位科学家获得更多的赞誉。门捷列夫很喜欢他的表，但当表的第一个空白被一个新命名的元素镓填补时，其他所有人都将发现它是多么的了不起。这是在1875年由一位法国人发现的。镓填补了铝正下方的空白，正因为如此……
Mendelea said should have properties like aluminum. But the French scientists who discovered and named gallium found that the melting point was different than what Mendelea predicted using the table. And Mendelea came back and said, no, I don't think that's right, you better check your results again, which is pretty insulting to say to another scientist. But Mendelea was not above insulting anybody. And after another year or so, it turned out that Mendelea was correct, and the Frenchmen had to retract his results. In the entire scientific world of chemistry was astounded that Mendeleev sitting in his
门捷列夫曾说过，它应该具备类似铝的属性。但发现并命名镓的法国科学家发现，其熔点与门捷列夫利用元素周期表预测的结果不同。门捷列夫回来后说，不，我认为那不对，你最好重新检查一下你的结果，这对另一位科学家来说可以说是相当侮辱人的。但门捷列夫从来不介意侮辱任何人。大约又过了一年，事实证明门捷列夫是对的，法国人不得不撤回他的结果。整个化学科学界都大为震惊，门捷列夫坐在他在圣彼得堡的办公室里……
office in St. Petersburg. He'd never seen the medal before. He knew nothing about the new element. But he had been able to see the properties of Gallien more clearly than the person who had actually discovered it in Paris, who had actually held it in his hand. Just because of the table, because he knew exactly where it was on the table, and what properties it should have. That's when the periodic table stopped being just a clever and nice looking arrangement of elements, and really became a scientific tool that had real predictive power.
他以前从未见过这种金属。他对这个新元素一无所知。但他比在巴黎实际发现它、甚至亲手触摸过它的那个人，更清楚地看清了镓的属性。仅仅因为这张表，因为他准确地知道了它在表上的位置以及它应该具有的属性。正是在那个时候，元素周期表不再仅仅是一个巧妙且外观漂亮的元素排列，而真正成为一个具有真正预测能力的科学工具。
But for most of us who know nothing of the elements on the table, which I think is most of us, its major impact is as an object of art, a scientific icon, a poster to hang up between the Smiths and R.A.M. the infographic Apotheosis. This moment right now is especially intriguing when you're looking at the design of the periodic table because last spring, scientists announced the discovery of an element on the bottom row.
但对于我们大多数对表中的元素一无所知的人来说（我认为这是我们大多数人），它的主要影响是作为一件艺术品、一个科学标志、一张挂在The Smiths和R.A.M.乐队之间的海报，也就是信息图表的巅峰。此时此刻特别耐人寻味，当你审视元素周期表的结构时，因为就在去年春天，科学家们宣布在底层发现了一个新元素。
It was element 117. Whose temporary name is Ununseptium 117? Classic. And then actually completed the seventh row of the periodic table. It sort of squared it off in the bottom right corner. And this is the only time in history that we've ever had a complete and full periodic table. The rest of the elements were discovered in pretty haphazard order, so there are always gaps or holes.
它是117号元素。其暂定名称是石田/Ununseptium 117？经典。然后它实际上完成了元素周期表的第七行。它在右下角把它框了起来。这是历史上唯一一次我们拥有了一个完整且填满的元素周期表。其余的元素都是以相当杂乱无章的顺序发现的，所以总是存在空白或空洞。
But right now we have a full, complete and very attractive periodic table. So if you like your periodic table squared off and tidy, well this is the time to be alive, my friend. And given the fact that the elements along the very bottom row are very fragile, scientists don't know if they'll be able to complete the A-throw if that ever gets started. So scientists may be able to create one or two more elements to start a new row and create here is the correct word because these big new elements are made by smashing together other elements in a lab, but Sam keemed out that they'll
但现在我们有了一个完整、全面且非常吸引人的元素周期表。所以，如果你喜欢方方正正、整整齐齐的元素周期表，嗯，生在这个时代真是太好了，我的朋友。鉴于最底层这一行的元素非常脆弱，科学家们不知道他们是否能够完成第八行（如果它真的开始的话）。因此，科学家们或许能够创造出一两个新元素来开启新的一行，而“创造”在这里是正确的词，因为这些庞大的新元素是通过在实验室里将其他元素撞击在一起制成的，但萨姆·基恩指出，他们将……
be able to manufacture one that will fit into each and every column. So right now is not only the only time we've ever had a complete periodic table, but it could be the only real complete periodic table we'll ever have. Half-nim, Tantulum, Tuxedin, William, Osm, William. 99% Invisible with Produced by me, Roman Mars, with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design.
能够制造出一个适合每一个列的元素。所以现在不仅是我们唯一一次拥有完整元素周期表的时候，而且它可能也是我们唯一能真正拥有的完整元素周期表。铪、钽、钨、铼、锇、铱。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持，Lunar用创造力创造不同。这是KALW、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的项目。
To find out more, go to 99%invisible.org. go in the center for architecture and design. To find out more, go to 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欲了解更多信息，请访问 99%invisible.org。访问建筑与设计中心。欲了解更多信息，请访问 99%invisible.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。